this is how sexy girls are I was up
dinner once this girl leans over during
the meal and goes hey
I'm not wearing any underwear
it's like oh my God that's hot then I
realized why is that sexy doesn't work
for a guy I can't pull that off I lean
over during dinner hey
I'm not wearing any underwear
she's gonna go uh oh
what happened
laundry day diarrhea need a wet wipe
talk to me
yeah everything's different now you know
like uh one time I sat down with a girl
she goes just better she goes you don't
send dick pics do you I was like no no
she's like good dicks are gross
I was like well that
that's all I got
that was gonna be like my big reveal